good to see you as always thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the
program tell us why you've decided to go
hi
I think it's really important that
governments at all levels contribute to
these discussions and clear our part in
meeting our own obligations domestically
but encouraging greater progress
globally Scotland is the European
co-chair of an organization called the
under two Coalition which brings
together devolved governments like mine
with States regions across the world
together we represent something like 50
of the global GDP and many of the levers
for tackling climate change lie in our
hands so it's really important that
everybody with a part to play does that
to the full Scotland was also the host
of Corp 26 last year in Glasgow and the
Scottish government played a part in
putting some key issues at this court on
the agenda loss and damage for example
so again important to be here to be
encouraging collaboration and playing
our part in hopefully a good outcome
from this Corporation continue to
address the accelerating emergency of
climate change
but isn't that what Rishi sunak is doing
already I mean could you not have done
what you needed to do remotely
no I think having I think this is the
fifth Corp that I have participated in
and it's really important to be here to
be having the discussions to be playing
our part in finding the solutions now
Rishi sunak is here I welcome that I
think it is right that he is here but if
we look in a UK context at many of the
the decisions that will determine
whether or not the UK as a whole meets
its own climate obligations many of them
for Scotland are responsibilities of the
Scottish government renewable energy for
example Energy Efficiency changing how
we we travel so it's really important
that everybody was a part to play does
that to the full and I think it is vital
that the connections that are made here
are are made and that we all do that
work and if you speak to many
campaigners many governments
particularly from the global South they
warmly welcome Scotland's contribution
here generally on this issue but
particularly on the issue of loss and
damage without the intervention last
year of the Scottish government and this
is not just my view you hear this from
campaigners here it is unlikely that we
would be now seeing that issue with the
prominence that has in Egypt so I think
we've all got a part to play here
climate change affects all the visit
affects some more than others but every
single one of us has an obligation to
play our part in tackling it including
the leader of Glasgow city council Susan
Aitkin who's also gone even though she's
just announced um 120 million pound
black hole in the city's budget
yes Glasgow was the host of cop last
year Susan is here to hand on at the the
court responsibility to Egypt to Shamel
sheep this year Glasgow Scotland's
biggest city Scotland won't meet its
climate change targets if the city of
Glasgow doesn't do that you know I mean
I I'm not arguing with your line of
questioning here but why we're here but
actually what matters is what's been
discussed here what the focus is on
implementing the progress made at
Glasgow what the commitments will be
coming out of this cup climate change
you know even given the turbulence of
the year we've just lived through
climate change is the biggest obligation
the biggest challenge the world faces
right now if we don't all of us leaders
at all levels of government if we don't
take this seriously increasingly
seriously if we don't make the right
commitments Implement those commitments
then we're not going to have a planet
worth handing on to Generations to come
there are fewer more important things
than climate change but in the here and
now it's also important to
improving the security of an energy
supply of making energy more affordable
that is actually how we save the planet
as well so I I think there would be more
uh pertinent questions I think to ask
for people like me and Susan Aitkin if
we weren't playing our Phil Park in
discussions like this and not just
playing our part in discussions but
actually showing the leadership that we
need to see if the world is going to
properly address this challenge I
suppose
um my viewers and your constituents
might say what is important is the cost
of living crisis and it's costing money
to send you and others the Glasgow city
council Etc and also the carbon
footprint
look you will find here I'm here in the
the main Pavilion of cop27 and there are
Representatives around me of devolved
governments of uh States and other
countries of German lender that there
will be governments at all levels
represented here we would be abdicating
our responsibility if we weren't here
playing our part in meeting these
challenges there is of course a cost in
all sorts of ways to tackling climate
change but there is a much much bigger
cost associated with not tackling
climate change and that's how we've got
to see that the cost of living certainly
occupies my government day in and day
out right now but dealing with the cost
of living also at Necessities dealing
with the issues around climate change
the route to more secure energy to
cheaper energy is a transition away from
fossil fuels to renewable energy and
that is Central to the whole climate
change agenda again you know why is a
country like Scotland here Scotland is
an oil and gas producing country we've
got an obligation to show leaders [ __ ]
in that transition away from fossil
fuels notwithstanding the challenges and
the difficulties that present to us so I
think if you went and did a stop I
remember speaking to you on the ground
in Glasgow last year if you did a straw
poll around people represented here and
asked them whether they thought it was
important for Scotland to be represented
you'd get an overwhelming vote in favor
of that because there's a recognition of
the role we've got to play but also the
leadership that Scotland has shown
okay um I thought while I've got you on
Matt Hancock going into the jungle
I I think it's disgraceful actually I
I'm not particularly interested in how
he gets on in the jungle but you know
most of my interactions with Matt
Hancock over the past few years when he
was so uh UK Health secretary were over
covered and you know we're not yet
properly out of covert we certainly
haven't had uh the full public inquires
that we need to have and to see him I
think demeaning the office that he used
to hold and uh also I think doing a real
disservice to those whose wives have
been impacted by covert I think it's the
wrong decision but there are many many
more important things for all of us to
be focusing on right now than whatever
Matt Hancock chooses to get up to okay
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much for taking the time always
appreciated
and to you thank you